[Musique]
la neuvième édition du total est un
rendez vous familial qu occupe une place
essentielle dans la programmation des
théâtres et cette année elle accueille
pour la première fois l'association
scènes d'enfants assistance france qui
organise le tour de france à la réunion
donc c'est un parcours de 18 mois de
rencontres thématiques à travers les
territoires de métropole et d'outre-mer
sont destinés à mettre en lumière les
projets innovants qui font qu'ils font
vivre par le jeune public
j'ai fait état que vivent à destination
d'enfants 16h jeunesse et donc c'est un
projet qui est initié par l'association
mais qui aussi porté comme ça peut
l'être aujourd'hui par l'ensemble des
plateformes sur les territoires tour
d'enfance est un projet pour
réactualiser les données essentielle sur
les conditions de production et de
diffusion de spectacles vivants à
destination de l'enfance et de la
jeunesse
nous devons de nous adapter à leurs
exigences mais aussi à leurs attentes
c'est toi d'enfance et qu'à ce titre une
très belle initiative
comme je le dis dans mon allocution
c'est un vif plaisir de recevoir le loto
d'enfance pas et si la prog première
étape à la réunion et cette première
étape nous permet effectivement d'être
un peu les privilégiés de cette
rencontre avec nos partenaires c'est
partenaires et effectivement le
département est très contents de leur
sort
[Musique]